today on the matt well show elon musk
gets the me too treatment but any
semi-intelligent person can see the
smear campaign for what it is also a new
report says that well over 100 teachers
have been arrested for sex crimes just
this year alone are we finally going to
start talking about the public school
pedophilia epidemic and a groomer tries
to prompt her young son to promote
cross-dressing on camera but the
conversation doesn't go as she planned
and the new york times introduces a new
euphemism non-consensus realities what
does that mean in our daily cancellation
the most prominent trans medical
organization in the world is now calling
for us to affirm
eunuch as a valid gender identity all of
that and more today on the matt wall
show
[Applause]
[Music]
with everything going on in the news
it's basically impossible now to avoid
the abortion debate um and look you may
also think that uh this means that the
fight's coming to an end if we're
getting rid of roe v wade but abortion
legislation returning to the states
means the real battle is actually just
beginning
and there is no group in america better
position than 40 days for life to help
fight this battle 40 days for life has 1
million volunteers throughout the
country holding peaceful vigils outside
of abortion facilities may be surprised
to hear that their largest presence is
actually in blue states with california
being their biggest state so they're
down there they're in enemy territory
they're doing great work their vigils
have closed many abortion facilities
america and nearly half of those
facilities were in liberal states where
abortion will continue to remain legal
after the fall of roe from san francisco
to chicago to seattle hardly pro-life
areas to put it mildly volunteers have
guided abortion workers to have a change
of heart and to quit their jobs so as
this issue gets um out of dc finally 40
days for life is effectively changing
hearts and minds in their grassroots
movement and they're fighting for the
pro-life movement so check out their
locations and their podcast and their
new book what to say when the complete
new guide to discussing abortion at
40daysforlife.com
as we head into our opening topic today
i want to start by reminding you that my
film what is a woman will be released on
june 1st the backlash by the left
against this film has started to pick up
steam especially in the last day or two
um i expect it'll get much much worse
once the full movie is released and
everybody sees you know what we actually
have in this film it's impossible to
predict just how far they'll go in
trying to shut it down and punish
everybody involved especially me as the
guy in front of the camera but i
anticipate an intense
cancellation campaign
whatever happens though
it will be worth it because this film is
the most important thing i've ever done
in my career hands down and
maybe because i haven't done a lot of
important things and also perhaps maybe
the most important thing that i'll ever
do in my career now of course its
importance though and the cultural
impact that it can have that i believe
it will have
all depends on you know you actually
watching it people have to see it for it
to have any impact at all which is why
if you haven't yet i would urge that you
go to whatiswoman.com and sign up for a
membership today if you haven't been
uh remember if you've been kind of
considering becoming a member but you
haven't become one yet i think now is
the time to pull the trigger cancel
netflix you know one of those other
streaming services with a bunch of lame
woke content we're all signed up for
like 50 different streaming services you
don't even remember all the streaming
services you're signed up for uh cancel
one of them and sign up for the daily
wire we've got a lot more coming down
the pike aside from this film and you
don't want to miss any of it trust me
also i've got
many more crazy ideas for projects
floating around my
troubled head and it'll be a lot easier
to get the green light on those other
ones if this one is successful just a
little bit more incentive for you so
head to whatisawoman.com
and uh get signed up today now
the metoo movement with its believe all
women mantra fell by the wayside in
recent years thanks in part to the fact
that nobody could figure out what a
woman is it's hard to believe women if
you don't know
what is meant by the word i mean how can
i believe women if i don't know what you
mean when you say women
also of course the metoo movement chose
to put itself on pause conveniently uh
right around the time when a woman
accused joe biden of sexual assault this
was purely a coincidence no doubt the
metoo crusaders were just you know
exhausted they needed a vacation and
they took this vacation right at the
exact moment when the democrat
front-runner for the presidency was
accused of digitally raping one of his
aides when he was in the senate
that's entirely happenstance only a
conspiracy theorist would draw a
connection between the two
still
metoo's conspicuous silence only served
to further discredit a movement which
never should have had any credibility to
begin with
and in keeping with its habit of
disappearing and then reappearing at
politically convenient times
now it's back um
just in the nick of time to take down
elon musk a reported business insider
which was eagerly picked up and
amplified by every mainstream media
outlet within minutes of course claims
that musk sexually harassed a flight
attendant
a few years ago reading from the report
it says
spacex the aerospace firm founded by
elon musk's musk the world's wealthiest
man paid a flight attendant 250 thousand
dollars to settle a sexual misconduct
claim against musk in 2018. insider has
learned
now we can stop right there
um just for a moment
we haven't made it past the first
sentence and already there are red flags
all over the place the first major and
ultimately disqualifying red flag is the
timing of all of this which we'll talk
more about in a moment
but the other is the amount that musk
allegedly paid to settle the claim
so think about that we'll return to that
point too uh but the amount is very
interesting for now let's keep reading
says the attendant worked as a member of
the cabin crew on a contract basis for
spacex's corporate jet fleet she accused
musk of exposing his erect penis to her
rubbing her leg without consent and
offering to buy her a horse in exchange
for an erotic massage according to
interviews and documents obtained by
insider the incident which took place in
2016 is allegedly in a is alleged in a
declaration signed by a friend of the
attendant and prepared in support of her
claim the details in this story are
drawn from the declaration as well as
other documents including email
correspondence and other records shared
with insider by the friend
now it's explained that this flight
attendant who also had a license as a
massage therapist went back to musk's
cabin on his private jet to give him a
full-body massage at which point she
claims or rather
someone else claims that she claims so
this is a claim being made on someone
else's behalf
so it's a she said she said situation
and the claim is that she was sexually
propositioned by musk who exposed
himself to her allegedly she refused
left the room and in the ensuing days
and weeks she alleges or her friend
alleges that she alleges she saw her
hours cut back at her job and she
determined that she was being pushed out
in retaliation
she was then supposedly paid 250 000 in
exchange for remaining silent about the
incident for his part musk says that
this is all a
politically motivated attack and anybody
with an iq above room temperature can
see that it is exactly that
and we know this for a few reasons
first as mentioned
the amount of the alleged settlement
musk is
worth more than 200 billion dollars
if you have a legitimate harassment
claim against a man with pockets as deep
as that against against the richest man
in the history of the world in fact
then you would not take a measly 250
grand for your silence
for a billionaire 250 000 is what you
pay to get rid of a nuisance
the payment if there was a payment at
all
doesn't indicate that this woman
actually had career and life destroying
dirt on musk it indicates rather that
she was an annoyance to him and that
musk could deal with it by just sort of
throwing pennies at her pennies by his
standards anyway
but the bigger red flag of course
and the thing that just disqualifies the
whole story
right away is the timing so let's follow
the timeline here
musk
makes an offer to buy twitter
the left is very upset put it mildly
then musk says that he's going to start
voting republican
the very next day
the media drops the sexual harassment
story the next day
the timing is not quite as transparent
as christine ford deciding that she was
raped by kavanaugh at precisely the
moment when kavanaugh was nominated to
supreme court
but it's pretty close timing-wise
and this is the point
if you have a harassment or assault
claim to make against somebody
and you wait until a politically
expedient time to make it
even if it's true it's still your fault
when the claim is disbelieved and
dismissed
now this fake incident happened four
years ago this friend quote unquote had
four years to alert the world to the
horrific deeds committed by elon musk
four years to do instead she waited
until right after musk came out as a
republican
now musk himself predicted a few days
ago that the political attacks against
him would get worse and he was right of
course he was right
because we know that the left
will stop at nothing
to punish anybody who defies it
the more egregious your defiance the
worse the attack will be
the more effective you are in opposing
them the worse the attack will be
and if the attacks work right
if they succeed in turning public
opinion against someone with lies and
slander that only encourages them to do
it more
and to do it to more people
to claim more victims
that's why as a as a matter of common
sense
but also simply as a matter of
self-preservation
our reflexive response to any
transparent left-wing smear campaign
must be to discount it dismiss it and
assume that it's false
we must do that even though on occasion
some of the dirt they throw around about
one of their targets may have an element
of truth to it
every once in a while who knows
like when they're trying to destroy
someone and they just start throwing
everything against the wall he did this
he did that
some of the stuff might be true who
knows
but we can't sift through the dirt
to try to discern what's true and what
isn't
that they've already won when you do
that
and you've encouraged them to continue
with these tactics in the future
if you have something to say about
somebody something to reveal you know a
deep dark secret you feel needs to be
brought into the public
don't dump it as part of a coordinated
political revenge campaign
if you do that you deserve to be ignored
and as for us again this is it's a it's
a matter of self-preservation
the left starts doing this to people
and they're only getting more egregious
they're getting more blatant about it
like what they just did to madison
cawthorn like if they don't like you
they're going to rip you apart they're
going to throw everything they have
and our only response should be simply
to just
dismiss it
we're not going to pay attention to it
sorry
nice try
moving on
now let's get to our five headlines
[Music]
all right well
speaking of sexual harassment and sexual
assault claims here are some uh assault
and harassment claims that we should
actually be paying attention to
um and not just claims by the way these
are not claims but actual arrests and
convictions so fox news has a story here
it says
at least 135 teachers and teachers aides
have been arrested so far this year
on child sex-related crimes in the u.s
ranging from child pornography to raping
students
135
this year
okay so that's like that's actually half
of a school year basically
an analysis conducted by fox news
digital looked at local news stories
week by week featuring
arrests of teachers and teachers aides
on child sex-related crimes in school
districts across the country arrests
that weren't publicized were not counted
in the analysis meaning the true number
may well be higher it certainly is
higher uh well the true number is
you know uh so so these are the arrests
that were publicized that got media
attention and that's what fox news is
compiling here and so they they come up
with 135.
well to get to the real number you also
have to factor in
the assaults and arrests and convictions
that did not get media attention and
then also for the for the true number
the truest number of all you have to
consider all of the crimes uh
uh assaults everything else
that we don't know about that were never
reported
where there was no arrest made
and anytime we we know this from
any other institution that's had this
problem including the catholic church
you know
if you've got x number of confirmed
cases
well in you know not every victim is
going to have to have actually come out
and uh and said something
so you can multiply that by who knows
five ten
when you factor in all of the victims
especially when the victims are children
in a public school setting
you're going to have a large
preponderance of of victims who
are too don't say anything because
they're afraid
or they do report it and they're just
ignored
continuing here it says the analysis
found that at least 135 teachers and
teachers aides have been arrested in 41
states between january 1st and may 13th
which works out to about an arrest a day
on average
the vast majority of the arrested
educators were men
and then they got a graph here 105 were
men
30 were women
which is still
certainly
many more men um
arrested for this but 30 women is still
in half a year
even that is a shockingly high statistic
shocking at least if you haven't been
paying attention to this problem um it
says of the arrest at least 102 uh
involved alleged crimes against students
and um and then you had others so there
were crimes against students and then
you also had crimes that they're that
they're including you know teachers who
were convicted of child pornography or
other crimes like that that did not
directly involve students that they were
teaching
this is
as i've been shouting
into the ether
for years
this is an epidemic
okay 100 you know 100 plus
teachers arrested in from january to may
of this school year
now if you
multiply that out
how many culprits do we have
in a given year
of the ones we know and don't know about
that's why i go i go back again to
the 2000 i think was 2004 department of
education did a report on this
you know um every once in a while like
maybe once a century the department of
education will actually do something
worthwhile and so this was their they
fit they filled their quota for this
century early on in 2004 they did their
one useful thing
and they actually did a report on this
and they looked into it and they told us
that there are thousands and thousands
and thousands of victims of sexual abuse
in the school system
and that and that in fact the problem is
100 times worse 100 times worse in the
school system than it is in catholic
church
this is finally after uh you know so
it's that was almost two decades ago the
department of education admitted that
they had this problem they admitted it
and everyone just went oh okay
completely ignored it
two decades later now we're finally
getting some headlines about it
um
any of these headlines are not enough
you know every once in a while we get uh
we hear
a sexual abuse epidemic
cover-ups and everything in a certain
institution
becomes massive news like the kind of
thing everybody is talking about
and and it's treated as it should be
it's a huge problem we have to do
something about immediately this
happened with catholic church it
happened in hollywood you know
the public school system still has not
gotten that treatment
will this be the thing well is this the
moment when the dam finally breaks
and there is kind of mainstream
acknowledgement of oh
dear god we have a major problem here
and considering we have 50 million of
our kids in this system we should
probably be paying attention to it
that's the thing that kind of was was
kind of blew my mind all along is that
you know
people cared very deeply about the uh
sexual assault epidemic in the catholic
church
even though many of the people who cared
about it were talking about it didn't
weren't catholics and they didn't even
have their kids in in the the churches
so their own kids were not
potential victims and yet they cared and
they should care
because there are victims and you should
care about that people cared a lot about
what's happening in hollywood even
though almost all the people talking
about it aren't in hollywood yet they
cared because they're our victims and
you should care about that so i get all
of that of course
but with the public school system
it you should care for all the reasons
you care about the church and about
hollywood but also
for for so many people your own kids are
in this system
so how many people like
well aren't catholics their kids don't
go to a catholic church their kids do go
to a public school
and yet they cared more
about the catholic church
scandal than about the one that affects
their own children
now that's what's hard for me to
understand you should care about all of
it but you would think as a parent your
first priority would be the epidemic
that could potentially affect your own
child
all right certainly not unrelated to the
first topic let's look at this here's a
video that went viral this week thanks
to um
libs of tick tock it's a a woman
grooming her son live on camera and in a
department store dressing room no what
appears to be a department store
dressing room no less
uh let's
watch some of this
okay hold on you love it
and you want it and you picked it out
but you don't
but you don't want it for school can you
tell me why
because last time i wore a dress to
school everybody called me a girl
oh
well what did we learn from my shadow is
pink
even when you wear a dress you're not a
girl
what makes a shirt for a boy or a girl
nothing
so do you want this you picked it out
i do want it you want to wear it all the
time at home but not at school right
yeah tell me about that i don't want to
get made fun of and that's what they
always do when i work
and stuff
i'm sorry not when i do it only on
special occasions
what makes you like dresses so much
i just like dresses
do you think bright pretty colors
and dresses and sequins and jewels and
golds all the things that you always
want to wear
do you think that's your innermost you
um
it is well how are you going to be your
innermost you when we live in a place
that people think clothing belongs to
particular gender
it's a trick isn't it
you know your mommy gets made fun of by
people for looking like this too
what do you think about that
nope
that's not that's
that's just wrong
what's the thing that always jumps out
at you when you watch when you see these
kinds of videos
of
parents grooming their kids
and filming it and then posting it
proudly and in this case
it's just made all the more disturbing
by the fact that she's in a she's in the
dressing room at a department store and
she's filming
her own kid
so what jumps out at you well of course
just how how outrageously disgusting all
of this is
right but but also what you notice with
the kid
like every time with these kinds of
videos and unfortunately there are many
videos like this
so the kid doesn't is not engaged okay
he's just a kid
i'm not sure how old this kid looks like
he's uh four maybe
four or five or so you know around there
and like any four or five-year-old kid
he's not he's just being a kid he's just
kind of bouncing around and and she's
interrogating him
trying to get him to say the lines that
she's fed him so that she can get it on
camera and post it on tiktok and get you
know and and be congratulated for it
but the kid's not even really
cooperating because uh he's just a kid
he doesn't care about this
like he actually
does not have any intense desire to wear
dresses
she's asking well why do you want to
wear a dress oh no
he doesn't care like you could easily
no even if the if the boy did have some
intense desire to wear dresses as the
parent you still say no
and if the desire is that intense you
know there's something psychologically
going on you give them some counseling
right if that's what it comes to but but
the point is in in like 99 percent of
cases wouldn't even be necessary
yeah that that that the child may have
maybe
at some point in the past expressed some
kind of desire to wear a dress to school
or something
i'm skeptical of that i mean it seems
apparent to me that she's been feeding
all of this to him from the beginning
but let's just say
that at some point a year ago you know
he said i wanna address i wanna wear a
dress at school
well it's really obvious in that video
that you could just say to the kid uh oh
no no boys don't wear that just wear
this instead and he'd be fine with it so
he doesn't care that much of course he
doesn't
okay breaking down gender barriers and
uh destroying the binary and all that
stuff no kid understands any of that or
cares about it that's not their priority
in life
this kid's bouncing off the walls he
just wants to go outside and play and be
a boy that's all he wants
okay leave the dressing room
this is for the mom leave the dressing
room to put the camera down you freak
your child abusing freak
bring your kid to a playground
and let him climb on the jungle gym
because that's all he wants to do
he doesn't want to be a part of this
but he also doesn't because because
unfortunately he's stuck with you and he
has no other frame of reference he
doesn't understand what's happening to
him
and he can't communicate
that he just wants you to shut the hell
up and let him live his life as a boy
from every single video like this
and this includes all the you know the
documentaries and reality shows they've
done
i am jazz whatever that hbo documentary
was last year
about the quote unquote trans kids and
all of those things when if you actually
watch and it's hard to stomach watching
any of it but it can be quite
instructive to watch a little bit of it
because this is what you always find is
that these young kids they they don't
care they're not invested in this what
is allegedly their innermost identity
and if they weren't allowed to express
it they would be in in despair and you
actually see it in real time and of
course they just they just don't care
they just want they just let them go
outside and play that's all they want to
do
stop stop
imposing
all of your
delusions and hang-ups and everything
and your ideology and all this stuff
and
hanging it around your
child's neck and forcing him to wear it
around
all right camila harris is uh speaking
out again about the horrific
implications of
killing fewer babies let's listen to her
overturning roe
opens the door to restricting those
rights
it would be a direct assault on the
fundamental right to self-determination
to live and love
without interference from the government
at its core
this is about our future as a nation
about whether we live in a country where
the government can interfere in personal
decisions
just it means nothing at all
so we don't have abortion legalized so
you can live in love without
interference what does loving have to do
with it yeah this is this is how i love
my child's by killing him of course
we've heard that that's
we heard it yesterday the daily
cancellation that's like explicitly what
these maniacs will say
but um also none of that just it's like
that's nothing but
meaningless cliche it doesn't mean
anything
people should be out allowed to live
without interference with the government
you don't believe that since when do you
believe camille harris that people
should be able to live without
interference with the government
you know it's nice that you're thinking
of that now i wish you thought of that
like two years ago
um
we just went through i mean what's the
vaccine mandates the lockdowns
everything there's a whole lot of
interference by the government
so it's like
democrats and leftists especially
of all people
don't believe that you should actually
be able to live without interference
from the government because they want
the government to infer constantly
interfere constantly all the time
and control nearly every aspect of your
life that's what they actually want
the only thing they don't want the
government to have any control over is
whether or not you kill your kid it's
the only thing they don't want the
government to have any say in right
but then also actually
nobody believes that we should be able
to live in love without interference
from the government
of course there are areas where the
government has unless you're an
anarchist okay unless you are a full-on
died-in-the-wool anarchist outside of
that and there's very few of those
they do exist but fine if you're if you
are an actual anarchist then you are i
think that your worldview is incoherent
but at least
you know you're allowed to go out and
say well people should be able to live
without interference in the government
because you really mean it
but if you're not an anarchist you don't
actually think that
like we all believe that the government
should be doing something
that you shouldn't be allowed to simply
live your life any way you want and do
whatever you want without the government
having us some kind of say in certain
circumstances at least
if you believe in in the concept of law
at all well you just heard there from
camila harris that is an argument
against law
as a concept
but she doesn't really believe that
actually
so none of this means anything speaking
of politicians making fools of
themselves if you haven't seen this clip
of george w bush from a speech this week
you have to watch it i mean this is one
of those things i saw people were
sharing it online and they were quoting
him
and what he says here and i
really thought i thought it was a joke i
thought it was some kind of
you know meme or something but no this
really did happen
watch this
in contrast
russian elections are rigged
political opponents
are imprisoned or otherwise eliminated
from participating in the electoral
process
the result is an absence of checks and
balances in russia
and the decision of one man
to launch a wholly unjustified
and brutal invasion of iraq i mean of
ukraine
all right anyway
75 uh
oh hilarious i mean he just
admitted that i mean there's there's no
other way to understand what you just
saw there other than this is a this is
like classic freudian slip
guilty conscience
how else do you make that mistake
you don't have to get into a lot of
psychoanalysis here to understand that
this is obviously this is how he sees
iraq and he knows at some level
that it was an unjustified
uh invasion
and then he kind of makes a joke he says
oh in iraq too and everybody laughs so
isn't that funny
it is interesting with george w bush
that there has been um
especially over the last few years and i
think donald trump had a lot to do with
this
um
because i think he was the first kind of
if you can call him uh i don't know
mainstream republican at least well you
know famous and
mainstream in the sense of being famous
well-known prominent um one of the first
to come out fully against
george w bush
criticizing his whole tenure the iraq
war and everything else not the first
probably to criticize the iraq war but
just his approach to the bush era
was uh different from how most
republicans approached it up to that
point and so now
um
there is
not bipartisan agreement on almost
anything
except that it's like almost everyone
agrees that the bush era in the bush
years was a total disaster which it was
um
being outdone now though by the biden
era and we're only one year into it
like i fully believe that george bush
and his uh his administration did
unfathomable damage to this country and
to the world
and we could start by before you even
get to the iraq war
uh the way that he expanded government
all of the agencies department of
homeland security tsa i mean that was
all his brainchild we have him to thank
for that
the part of homeland security you know
now they're going after
pta moms calling us domestic terrorists
that all goes back to george bush he
might not have had that in mind but he
started that
um
and now there's kind of like round
bipartisan agreement about about that
although
even keeping in mind all the damage bush
did um i think you could certainly argue
that biden in one year has done more
damage than bush was able to do at eight
so only imagine what we have in store
at least a year and a half anyway he's
done that much damage we'll see what the
next two and a half years have in store
for us
um i want to read this this is an
article published in the new york times
this week written by daniel bergner and
it promotes a new movement as they call
it
that seeks greater acceptance of
psychotics who hear voices in their
heads
these people are not delusional we're
told it is rather that they experience
quote non-consensus realities
that's the phrase they're going with
the article begins with a woman named
caroline maisel carlton who's been
hearing voices since she was a young
child
we're told that caroline started taking
antipsychotic medication in middle
school but over the years she became
less consistent and sometimes she
stopped taking the meds all together she
started doing drugs she was having
promiscuous sex with men this is all you
know what the story they have in the
article we're told for some reason that
she had an abortion they mentioned that
too of course
after a while she stopped the drugs
completely
and then this
she began leading hearing voices network
support groups reading now from the
article which are somewhat akin to
alcoholics anonymous meetings for people
with auditory and visual has nations the
groups with no clinicians in the room
gathered on second-hand chairs and sofas
in humble spaces rented by the alliance
what psychiatry term psychosis the
hearing voices movement refers to as
non-consensus realities and a bedrock
faith of the movement is that filling a
room with talk of phantasms will not
infuse them with more vivid life or
grant them more unshakable power then
things get a little more disturbing as
we're told quote
measle carlton also worked as a
sometimes staff member at firehouse a
temporary residence run by the alliance
as an alternate alternative to locked
wards
the people who stay at a fire are in
dire need many are not only in mental
disarray but also homeless many are
suicidal there are no clinicians on
staff no security personnel only people
who know such desperation first hand
in the living room a homemade banner
declares quote holding multiple truths
knowing that everyone has their own
accurate view of the way things are
the author then informs us that
antipsychotic medication for several um
uh
you know that antipsychotic medication
can make things worse he says sometimes
and he cites approvingly a world health
organization report which which he says
is quote a revolutionary manifesto on
the subject of severe psychiatric
disorders it challenges biological
psychiatry's authority its expertise and
insight about the psyche and it calls
for an end to all involuntary or
coercive treatment and to the dominance
of the pharmaceutical approach that is
foremost in mental health care
across uh conditions okay so in the
article it's actually a lengthy article
and
you know you start with this kind of
shocking thing about okay we're gonna
we're gonna be accepting of
if you're hearing voices you should
accept it and this is a it's not that
you're hearing an unreality it's a
non-consensus reality
that's going to be that's the new
euphemism now that we're going to use
so you start with that shocking thing
from there it goes on it's quite lengthy
again yeah there are some interesting
points that are made not everything in
the article is uh is is not is lacking
in in some kind of validity
um makes some good points about you know
the over reliance on
prescription medicines in general
especially when it comes to the
psychiatric psychiatry industry uh talks
about the horrific side effects of some
of these drugs i mean all that stuff is
valid interesting to talk about
and in a more normal healthy society
this is maybe a conversation we could
have
where you really get into the weeds and
you go in depth on like let's take
people who are
clearly severely mentally disturbed
they're hearing voices you know
and uh
what's the best approach
and that's potentially an interesting
conversation that we could have
but the problem is
uh you take a concept like
non-consensual reality
and we know where that leads and we're
hit where it's already led in fact
and the banner that's in this house
saying that well everybody has an
accurate view of the way things are well
no not everyone does in fact lots of
people do not have an accurate view just
because it's your view of the way things
are doesn't make it accurate it might be
your view
but it that doesn't lend it accuracy
just because it's yours
but this is taking the i'm living my
truth
idea
and taking it all the way to its
logical extreme
which is now which means that now we're
going to affirm even people who are
having
hallucinations
and then also this idea of well we we
need to which apparently the world
health organization has endorsed
uh the claim that we should end the
involuntary treatment of people we
shouldn't commit people involuntarily to
psychiatric institutions we shouldn't
treat them involuntarily and that to me
is obviously incorrect
and this is already a movement that's
well underway
you know there are still people who get
involuntarily committed to mental
asylums and that sort of thing but it's
not nearly as common as it used to be
you know uh not nearly it doesn't have
nearly as often as it used to
and
where are these people now is it because
we have fewer crazy people
the the reason historically why you
would commit someone even involuntarily
to what we used to call insane asylums
is if they are a danger to the public if
they're delusional you know
schizophrenic hearing voices
hallucinating and they're a danger to
people
or to themselves
and that's why you would commit them
because what else are you gonna do
well we're seeing the consequence now of
what happens when you don't commit these
people
um you just look out on the streets
in los angeles san francisco or new york
that's where a lot of the people end up
they're not being committed and so
they're living out on the street and
they're you know
randomly throwing women in front of uh
of of trains on the subway in new york
that's that's what ends up happening
when you don't
when you've ruled out the possibility of
in even involuntarily treating people or
committing them
lots of problems with this idea as it's
presented in the new york times article
and um
not the least of which
non-consensual reality but that's i'm
telling you right now you heard it here
first well you didn't hear it from me
first you're from new york times but
this is going to be
that's a euphemism that i believe you're
going to hear a lot more of
applied to not just
people who hear voices but
expanding far beyond that
um
let's see what else do we got
one other clip we have time to play i
think we have time to play one of the
clip i wanted to play uh so brookline
public school had a racial justice and
solidarity day at school where they had
some white people on stage and they were
confronting their demons as white people
and let's watch a bit of that
i don't think there's another way i
could live i do racial justice and
liberation work
because i i see
my white advantage everywhere i go and i
also see the way white supremacy
capitalism patriarchy
are locking me into systems that are
really not working for me either as a
white person it's jacking up my
relationships it's jacking up my kid's
school system it's jacking up the
healthcare system it's jacking up my
relationship with the environment and i
really feel like a lot of these systems
just need to be hospiced out
and we need an entirely new way of
engaging with each other that is much
more radical and loving so
for me racism is operating all the time
i think you guys got the definition a
system of advantage based on race that's
david wellman's definition
so um there's nowhere where it's not
operating does anyone know when brooklyn
high founded 18
1834
i wrote it down somewhere so you know
this this building
was built during chatter slight shadow
slavery so there's there's really no
part of where we are that hasn't been
touched by structural racism and
intersecting forms of oppression so i
got to do this work yeah i gotta get
free i feel like my life depends on it
so i'll pass it like ann braden says i
know it's crazy that you know far right
people are going after critical race
theory i'm a critical race practitioner
like that is the way school should be
taught the only thing it's doing is
asking how is racism operating here it's
not that complicated right it's an
incredible theoretical practice so i
hope that the school considers like
actually teaching critical race and then
go to the media and tell everybody
you're doing it
so critical race theory uh doesn't exist
i don't know it does exist but it exists
but it's only
it's only in uh you know higher level
academics and law school and stuff
or no but then we hear there that it's
actually a good thing in that and that
it should be taught in in school so it's
really that's non-consensual reality
right so whatever whatever reality they
need to be whatever reality they prefer
in in any given moment is what they'll
go with and so that's what we hear there
um
and but also remember that you know
replacement theory
is a horrible racist trope
meanwhile they've got
white people up on stage there
apologizing for their whiteness
and talking about races one of the most
uh brilliant
and also devious things that the left
has has done in in the last 50 years
is uh and it always begins of course
with redefining words right and so the
what they've done the way they've
redefined racism
so much of their of the work like they
like to talk about it got to do the work
well so much of the work that they do
on the topic of race begins with this
starting point of redefining racism
and taking it away from something just
like they've done with every other word
including a woman uh taking it away from
something that was simple and
straightforward everybody knew what it
was okay you're racist if you hate other
races you feel like you're superior to
them well then you're racist pretty
pretty pretty simple you know and uh the
advantage of having a simple definition
is that you can easily identify racism
when you see it
and there's not a lot of controversy
about it
take it no it's that's not what it is
instead it's about it's about systems
and it's about advantage and it's all
these things
they never have to
like there's
there was a a point in time a point in
history
when people we know who these people
were came along
and took the word racism and just
declared that it has a new definition
and they never have to explain that
or explain why we should listen to the
people who redefined it
why why do we have to go with their
definition
never have to explain it because this is
their reality their non-consensual
reality uh or non-consensus reality
let's go now to the comment section
we become insane
here in the straight baby gang
[Music]
erica says i always appreciate matt's
take on homeschooling one thing that
always boggles my mind is when people
talk about homeschool kids not being
social enough when the very structure of
public school is designed to limit
social interaction any parent of young
girls in public schools can tell you
that teachers constantly complain that
their daughters talk too much
just as boys learn through hands-on and
activity
active learning activities girls learn
through socially interacting with their
peers being social and communicating
with others helps young girls to become
empathetic and nurturing but in public
school this social behavior is actively
discouraged of course there's a time and
place for children to learn and be quiet
and respectful but public school kids
are expected to sit idly full time
from the age of five
uh that's a really good point too and i
often talk about
you know maybe because i can i'm
drawing from my own experience in public
school
when i was a child but i often talk
about the way the public school doesn't
work for boys because of as you
mentioned
boys are more active and they want to be
up and moving around and doing things in
a kind of hands-on way the public school
environment cannot cater to that so
instead they make these kids sit down
and if they are not able to sit down and
sit still then either they become
they're now troublemakers and they end
up in that system and they're getting
suspended and getting detention
everything or
and or you start drugging them
so that that's the way that uh
public school system doesn't work for
boys
but then as you bring up it also this
also applies to girls too of course now
girls thrive in the public school system
more than boys do
as all statistics show us
but the system isn't great for any kid
and girls too
and you bring up an interesting reason
why
that's uh yeah you do need to teach kids
how to sit still
for for periods of time how to be quiet
and respectful and all that
but it's not natural
for you know a nine-year-old child boy
or girl
to be sitting down at a desk doing busy
work for six to seven hours a day
uh
let's see
chris says
matt i know how much you love righteous
anger and getting back at people but the
joe what's her name bit smacks of taking
the bait she's clearly fishing for
outrage in a way that the woman
testifying the congressional hearing was
not a notch beneath you chum and to make
things worse she got one over on you and
any other conservative with her bigger
name than she has
uh i don't think it's taking the bait at
all in fact i i totally disagree with
you
you're talking about joe
from the daily cancellation yesterday
who said that she would rather abort her
kids you rather kill her child and let
her child be adopted by uh by white
parents
and you think this is just trolling
looking for attention
uh there may be an element of that but i
actually but i don't think that's the
primary point here
i think what she wants and it's pretty
clear from her reaction what she wants
and expects is that she can say these
horrific things
and most people will just applaud her
for it
okay there may be some people out there
that are out trolling and looking for
negative reactions but especially on the
left that's not primarily what most of
these people want
they want the opposite they want to be
applauded they need to be applauded and
affirmed all the time
and so she says this horrific thing and
what she wants is for anyone who
disagrees to just ignore it
and then she only wants to hear from the
people that affirm it so that she can
feel better and more comfortable and
safer
with this terrible viewpoint
so i think by ignoring it that is what's
taking the bait that's what's giving her
what she wants
and allowing her to be affirmed
now by me responding to it
it sent a flood of people in her
direction who were horrified by the
horrific thing that she said
and that's the reaction that you should
get in a civilized society when you say
out loud that you'd rather your child be
dead than adopted by a race that you
don't like
in a civilized decent society um people
should react to that in an outraged and
uh horrified way
uh
jay says matt you're one of the best
social commentators out there but your
insistence on intentionally
mispronouncing democratic party names
i.e karen gene pair
and others doesn't serve you well
everybody deserves to have their names
pronounced correctly even incompetent
unqualified and income poops like the
above it's pretty cringe-worthy cheap
shot it's not worthy of your comedic
chops which are substantial
jay i don't know what you're talking
about i really don't
i try my best okay
i try my best to pronounce people's
names correctly
this feels like this is a little bit
ableist on your end frankly
maybe i i suffer from some sort of
mental i from some sort of mental
disability in fact probably many and one
of them makes it difficult for me to
pronounce names and i don't
i don't appreciate this from you in fact
you're banned from the show actually for
that
um
david says with all due respect pregnant
men are not the only men liberals defend
any man competing in women's sports has
the full backing and support of the
democrat party you're right about that
except that of course on the left they
would say that the man competing in
women's sports is not a man
so my point is that the only time
they'll actually say man in like a
positive way
the only time that they will verbally
defend
a man
and using that word is if it's a
pregnant man
of course but that's not really a man as
we know
that is the only time you'll hear them
actually say the phrase um
a phrase like well men should be
included don't don't don't ostracize men
men should be involved too well you know
there are men also like any phrase like
that you'll never hear that from them
ever except when it comes to pregnancy
that's the only time
this may come as a great shock to you
but in addition to being incredibly
one-sided mainstream media is also
extremely boring you know exactly what
everybody's going to say
but that's not the case with sunday
special the weekend edition of the ben
shapiro show not boring at all imagine
if you will a show that has guests with
different points of view if you can
imagine ezra klein zooby brett easton
ellis they've all been on the show
that's because at the daily wire we
follow the truth wherever it goes it's
certainly true with the greatest lie
ever told also our upcoming documentary
with candace owens it's a hard-hitting
expose about the death of george floyd
in the rise of blm you don't want to
miss that it's also true on this week's
sunday special with ben's guest jonathan
isaac he'll be discussing why i stand
the new book he just released with the
daily wire isaac was the lone nba player
not to neil for the national anthem
during a league-wide demonstration in
support of black lives matter his story
is courageous and inspiring sunday
special will be available this sunday
morning on apple podcast spotify or
wherever you listen to podcasts always
very interesting we know this is going
to be an extra interesting one so make
sure you tune in for that now let's get
to our daily cancellation
[Music]
it should hopefully be clear to you by
now that we are not on a slippery slope
per se there's no slippery slope anymore
the word slope makes our current process
of societal disintegration sound far too
orderly and gradual we've long since
slipped all the way down the slope and
that's why i prefer to compare our
cultural situation something more along
the lines of george clooney in that
space movie with sandra bullock if i
remember the plot point correctly
clooney becomes untethered from the
space station somehow during a spacewalk
and then hurtles out into the cold abyss
while sandra bullock just waves goodbye
makes no attempt to rescue him and
that's us we are tumbling untethered
into the darkness we're not going in any
particular direction but simply out into
the void
where there is neither up nor down
nor warmth nor light
happy friday by the way the point is we
should not be terribly surprised by the
news first reported by the website redux
that the most prominent influential
trans medical organization in the world
wpath
has been using a castration fetish site
as a reference and resource for its
guidelines
now you're probably confused
but you also probably don't want to
learn more
but you will i'm afraid the daily caller
has a helpful summary of the story
reading from their report they say the
world professional association for
transgender health wpath
developed its latest medical guidelines
using information from a site that hosts
pedophilic fantasy pornography and
castration fetish content
wpath which sets medical standards for
transgender medical procedures according
to u.s
assistant secretary for health rachel
levine released new draft guidelines
december on december 3rd which include
unic
as a gender identity
the organization pulled information from
a website called unik archive which
hosts thousands of members who discuss
their castration fantasies and according
to wpath hosted a popular post popular
post providing instructions for
self-castration
wpath referenced stories of
self-castration shared on the site to
argue that healthcare providers must
castrate individuals for their own
safety if they believe a person will
likely chemically or surgically castrate
themselves outside of the formal medical
setting otherwise
the unix archives the unique archives
fiction archive which the wpath guidance
described as filled with fantasy
contains hundreds of erotic fantasy
stories about castration child
castration pedophilia sexual torture
performing medical experiments on
prepubescent boys slavery fetishes and
racial abuse
and actually the description of this
website goes on from there and i can't
even read like that's the most i can
read of describing what's on this
website i can't even read more than that
to you because it gets bleeped out
now i wanted to confirm that wpath
actually does endorse unic now as a
valid gender identity so i went to the
wpath website myself and sure enough i
found this quote
this is from wpath website among the
many people who who benefit from gender
affirming medical care those who
identify as eunuchs are the least
visible the eighth version of the soc
standards of care includes a discussion
of unique identified individuals because
they're indeed present and in need of
gender affirming services for the
purposes of standards of care we define
munich as an individual assigned male at
birth whose testicles have been
surgically removed or rendered
non-functional and who identifies as a
eunuch
the identity of eunuch is a gender
identity of its own and for many it is
the soul identity with no other gender
or transgender affiliation
now it goes on for a while longer
talking about eunuchs men who wish to be
castrated or who are castrated in
pursuit of some perverse and
inexplicable sexual
satisfaction
and wpath goes to great lengths to
explain that this is all valid and
good and healthy
the important thing to emphasize here is
that
although wpath may not be an
organization that you recognize by name
it is nonetheless hugely prominent and
influential
government policy and medical guidelines
are written
based on declarations made by this
institution
as referenced in the daily caller
article you may remember a few weeks ago
when rachel levine of the health and
human services said that there is no
argument quote unquote against medically
transitioning children fox news reached
out to levine's office for further
comment
and like an explanation about this
statement and this is what they reported
quote there is no debate in the medical
community about the medical or
scientific validity of gender affirming
care levine's communication director
adam sarvana told fox news sarvana said
the standards of care from world
professional association for transgender
health wpath have been endorsed by
multiple medical organizations including
the american academy of pediatrics the
american medical association the
american psychiatric association and the
american academy of child and adolescent
psychiatry
now he's right by the way
there is almost no debate in the medical
community about so-called gender
affirming care and it is true that all
of those other medical organizations
look to wpath as an unquestioned
authority on anything related to gender
or gender identity
which only further demonstrates the
abysmal state of the medical community
and now this unquestioned authority says
that it is valid
to be a eunuch
in fact they recommend in their
guidelines that doctors castrate
self-identified units in order to help
them fully live out and realize their
identities
see this is why i say we've devolved way
past the point of slippery slope
we've now entered a vortex where all
impulses proclivities fantasies
perversions
non-consensus realities
must be affirmed and i do mean all
this is what some on the right have been
slow to understand about the
transgenderism push
you know that was not one small
progression
it wasn't one slight deviation away from
reality it's not one gradual step
towards insanity no once you've
introduced the concept of pregnant men
and women with penises
once you've done that you've obliterated
reality completely
because it's not really possible to come
up with a more radical departure from
reality than that
you haven't slipped down the slope
you've gone all the way to the bottom of
the slope and it's just like you've
leap-frogged over a bunch of other stuff
and now we're just going to circle back
and cover that stuff too
or going back to the analogy you've
officially left the space station and
now you're floating out there in the
ether
so we we react with justified horror at
wpath trying to normalize unix but in
fact this isn't any more horrifying than
anything else wpath has normalized
it's entirely consistent with their
overall mission
and it follows from their one single
rule which is the rule of all leftists
which is that everything must be
affirmed
everything
as long as it's not normal
or natural or healthy
for good
and that is why today
wpath is uh cancelled
a little bit of a heavy subject to end
on for a friday but that's just the way
it is we'll talk again on monday have a
great weekend godspeed
[Music]
the matt walsh show is produced by sean
hampton executive producer jeremy boring
our supervising producer is mathis
glover production manager pavo valdoski
our associate producer is mckenna waters
the show is edited by robbie dantzler
our audio is mixed by mike coromina and
hair and makeup is done by cherokee
heart the matte wall show is a daily
wire production copyright daily wire
2022. hey everybody this is andrew
clavin host of the andrew clavin show
you know some people are depressed
because the republic is collapsing the
end of days is approaching and the moons
turn to blood but on the andrew clavin
show that's where the fun just gets
started so come on over to the andrew
clavin show and laugh your way through
the fall of the republic with me andrew
clavin